je déjà c'est un film alors après le
café du cadran qui a été un succès j'ai
eu une étiquette dans mame une étiquette
sur mon personnage j'étais devenu un
acteur humain mais c'est très important
ça l'étiquette pour un comédien et c'est
même dangereux parce que quelquefois on
s'en sort pas c'est un peu ce qui s'est
passé dans mon corps j'ai tourné
beaucoup de films à l'époque qui étaient
des films humain je travaillais dans
l'humain ça ne venait pas de moi ni des
auteurs ni des metteurs en scène n'en
savenay des exploitants c'est à dire des
directeurs de salles qui disent aux
distributeurs qui le distribue les films
comme vous savez qui ces mêmes
distributeurs le dise aux producteurs
auxquels il donne de l'argent pour
produire blier paye dans l'humain
c'était le moment où je payais dans
l'humain alors on m'a fait tourner ses
personnages là j'en ai tourné pas mal et
puis après j'ai été le mari trompé
patenté du cinéma français le café du
canon étant le premier film de cocu que
j'ai fait j'ai été le plus grand cocus
de l'histoire du cinéma français s'est à
tel point j'en ai la nausée et c'était
c'est un point tel que même si on me
disait demain tu vas jouer le
misanthrope ou l'école des femmes je
dirais non aucun casting au qg en veut
plus oui à quel point on peut être
déformé par les inventions des
exploitants qui sont d'ailleurs les gens
qui font leur métier me disant
simplement qu'ils achètent de l'acteur
qui vendent de la pellicule
là je crois que nous pouvons conclure en
somme les comédiens veulent bien être
confondu avec le personnage ou le rôle
qu'ils interprètent à la condition que
ce personnage soit sympathique et si
bernard blier ne veut pas être pris pour
un caucus et parce que ça n'est jamais
agréable dans la vie de penser qu'on est
qu tueur mais par exemple s'ils avaient
été appelés à jouer des rôles de don
juan et bien je crois que si on l'avait
confondu avec son personnage ça ne leur
ait pas été tellement désagréable
il ya une chose que vous voulez
certainement savoir c'est si nos rôles
nos personnages nous influence dans la
vie je m'explique si par exemple le fait
de jouer un assassin nous donne de
mauvais instinct ou bien au contraire
par réaction nous rend meilleurs je
pense quelquefois que si je n'avais pas
été actrice
j'aurais peut-être été dans la vie un
personnage terrible monstrueux qu'en
fait il ya quelque chose d'assez rare
impossible et invraisemblable et
oh